so there's two main parts to the
University there's the research
enterprise and there's the educational
enterprise and I definitely see both
parts of it changing a lot in the next
decade or so so speaking about the
educational Enterprise it's not enough
for people to learn the skills that
they're learning today as valuable as
they may be but it's it's going to be
very important for them to learn
innovation skills that enable them to
better communicate their ideas and
communicate a value proposition figure
out how to make greater impact with
their ideas by enrolling other people in
their vision and to understand how to
finance their idea and how to turn it
into a sustainable business nonprofit
whatever form it is and so that's going
to be really important as we think it's
especially important at the phd level we
think that that's something that's been
ignored the fact that PhDs in fact Kurt
Carlson who's a CEO of SR I
international they're a nonprofit
research lab in Menlo Park he was who's
giving a talk recently and he where he
said that their PhD students they get
they get the most amazing PhDs around
the world to come around the country to
come and work for them and despite that
it takes them seven to ten years to
become fully productive members of the
team and why is that it's because they
lack the innovation skills they lack the
skills of understanding how they fit
into the innovation ecosystem how they
fit in how they communicate their ideas
and how they address real-world problems
so that's a perfect validation for the
fact that you USC were just announced
and we're launching for the Fall a
innovation diploma program for PhD
students that's free of charge for PhDs
it's a three course sequence unlike any
other program that we're aware of and we
think it's really really valuable for
our students to not we're not trying to
turn PhDs into business people we don't
think that's appropriate we don't think
that it always works what we want to
keep them as researchers and the cutting
edge of their field and that's that's
their whole
goal is to become the absolute best in a
discipline and there have been some
criticisms that academics don't
understand the bigger picture or they
don't they're too specialized the
reality is if you're going to be the
absolute best you have to be very
specialized but that doesn't preclude
you from understanding how to
communicate with others that can take
your idea and make it into something
really impactful so it's sort of
bridging that gap by making both the
academics aware and then of course we'd
like to focus on the the business
community as well to bring them closer
to academia
there's a lot of changes that are
happening now that are really going to
be impacting the way innovation happens
in the University one of them for
example is open access to research
results and people are publishing
increasingly in open access journals and
in fact I think they've been about 5,000
new open access journals that have
popped up online in the last couple
years they're circumventing the typical
peer-reviewed printed journal
publications and that's really having
that will have some significant effect I
think in the future and it's not just a
matter of open access to the papers but
also there's been a greater drive
towards open access towards the the data
itself which starts to it's somewhat
controversial because there's definitely
an interest by faculty with all the work
that they put into collecting that data
and this has been a challenge for for a
while but it's exacerbated by this new
open access is how do you get the get to
benefit from your own data that you've
worked so hard to collect and then and
publish on so how long is it appropriate
to hold back that data before you share
with other people obviously the sooner
you get the data out there the more
people will benefit and at the same time
you need to motivate faculty to be
collecting that data in the first place
and so that's that will be an
interesting thing to see also digital
scholarship is changing the output of
research so it used to be that you can
do some research you can write it up in
a thesis or a paper publish it or put it
on a bookshelf and and that was your
publication that's not going to cut it
anymore you have digital multimedia
output that how do you archive that so
for example we have this program this
the system that was developed at USC in
collaboration with some other
universities called hyper cities it was
developed by historian in fact
at USC and Phil ethington and what it is
is you can put geo rectified maps and
geo tagged photographs into the system
and you can look at for example I can
look at my neighborhood and then click
on a button it's a nichoza view from the
from the sky the satellite view down
into well let's see what the map looked
like from 1986 now let's see this other
map from 1920 and you realize my god
there's no marina there and you can
really go through it's almost like going
through time and seeing how things were
you can look at different photographs
and very much in a crowdsourcing fashion
it enables other historians now its
platform where other people can add to
this archive of information so it brings
up some interesting questions one of the
questions is how do you how do you store
and that kind of output if it's not a
piece of paper that you can put in a
library or you can scan in how do you
archive this how do you enable people to
access that information and if you are
allowing people to contribute to it and
how do you give proper credit to those
individuals that are contributing to
this piece of scholarship if there's now
hundreds of people that are contributing
to this so this is very different it's a
brave new world it's different from the
way it was say 20-30 years ago and it's
going to continue to change